i mean i know you have your outline but
at what point are you really honing in
on that dialogue
um i you know when i'm doing the outline
i'm not
if i have a line that comes up you know
i'll throw it in just for my own
sake so i remember it but i'm i'm
running those scenes in my head
you know about what what people are
gonna say and you know
the characters and when you know
this is the first time you're gonna sit
down and craft the scene
so you two have never been together and
i have to write it
and if i if i stand that character's
voice in my head
for the most part it'll continue through
but then you do another pass and
redefine and say man they really
wouldn't say that and
and this and that so um you know first
draft is good for that is to be with
your characters
and sort of sussing out the first time
and it may not be perfect it won't be
about their voice because you got to
find you got to get a handle on that
for the different characters um so
uh it helps you know like when you do
your character profiles
if you decide to sit down like an actor
would and really suss it out
to think of how this character speaks
what their point of view is you know
things like that because many times i do
read scripts and
you could take the names off from
characters and they kind of sound
like the same person and that's
something you don't want
it should be like you take the names off
and i go ah i knew who that is
oh i know what this is you know it has
to be that distinct because otherwise it
just all blends into
people just saying things and they
people don't speak the same way
you know and at what point do you thin
out the dialogue or
maybe you don't need to in that you
start to read it and go you know
this just sounds too like people
wouldn't really say this let me thin
this out
have it be more modest second draft okay
yeah or usually it gets the the notes
about cut this speech or
you know cut the first line out you're
saying the same thing and
and that's you know it's second draft
should be more
you know redefining not like throw that
out
let's you know and i've worked on
scripts like that you know it's a script
doctor
where it's like this is complete you see
everything that you're reading here yeah
you can't use it oh it gives you the
title the character names
everything's got to be recalibrated
rewritten
um so second draft is great for going
through that and polishing up and
then you know you put it away for a week
and you come back to it
and it really is glaring like did i
write that you know
um this does it bumps for me this
character doesn't sound like
and and many times uh people find it's
good to speak the dialogue
aloud you know or have table reads
where they can hear it uh you know like
like they do with plays you know it's
like
that doesn't quite sound like that
character and then an actor is a good
is a good person for that to really
you know read it and go this kind of
doesn't you know what i mean
like in a reading an actor would take
the character in and
and go it's done right sound right you
oh okay you know if you're workshopping
that type of thing
if if someone can't get a bunch of
actors together for whatever reason
would it be helpful maybe to speak into
a tape recorder their idea oh sure
and the software's the software has um
you know you can put it it really read
the script for you you can listen
so but the voice is is okay you know
but yeah it'd be good i speak
you know the dialogue people probably
what's the guy talking to himself you
know
[Laughter]
like oh i'm crazy i decide to be a
writer you know
these people leave you alone on the
street yeah exactly yeah
i'm writing i'm writing constantly in my
head you know
how do you know you're getting the
dialogue right again
i i feel you know i mean personally for
me it's a feel and a feeling
and sound you know and and and vision
about you have to really know your
characters to write each one
individually and what they would say and
more importantly what they would not
you know a lot of time dialogue is
written and i see a scene and i'm like
you know this character doesn't have to
say that line
let them emote you know with you know 60
feet on the screen with a look rather
than
you know you want to err on action first
and dialogue second
you know so um dialogue is extremely
important but
that shouldn't drive your you know it
shouldn't drive
the narrative by people speaking because
most time people don't say what they
mean
you know so a lot of times it's going to
be like the subtext below that about
what they
really mean you know and dialogues
it's hard to do well you know you read
things and like i said you've got
characters that
all sound the same and it's just sort of
like it sits there on the page and it's
not
you know i could strip the name off and
i would go i they both sound like the
same person
you know so it it takes time
and and like we discussed earlier about
maybe
you know tape it you know with your
phone or something and listen back and
if it doesn't say you know that's the
thing about sound
the way people talk their diction what
they would
what they would say what they wouldn't
say what they would reveal and not you
know
the tone the tone sure exactly because
you could say one thing it would sound
completely friendly and kind of another
and it's just a matter of tone
and then when you start working with
actors that's like the workshop level
because
they'll take your piece and go okay and
then internalize it and then go
this doesn't because i've seen it on
sets where the actors like
i don't this doesn't work for me you
know
i need to change this and it's like okay
songs are not
too changed because you know you take
that line out earlier
you know we're talking about big rewrite
but you know i mean internalizing it and
saying
because now i know my my character
wouldn't really say that
and you go okay that's fair you know in
writing it i thought it would and now on
the set it doesn't work
you know so there's there's that thing
so it's constant
evolving uh you know entity is
the screenplay you know because you're
you're shooting it for the first time
and
you know it's create creative process
things there's choices made on the set
all the time
you